hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts animal models for
tuberculosis research presented by young
tech search assistant professor at the
Department of Biological Sciences
University of Notre Dame
I am Marjorie Torres of labyrinth and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
reads labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask the question box located on
the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appears on the screen what answer
is many of your questions it's real time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
this button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Zhang Cheng I'll announce in the
presentation over to him
mr. Byam module my name is Yong Chun
from a university of notre dam I'm
currently a research assistant professor
work you know projects understanding the
mechanisms on their host and pathogen
interactions in the context of
Mycobacterium typical infection
today I will talk about a new models for
tuberculosis research before I started
the talk I would like to thank all our
conference organizers for giving me this
great opportunity so I miss you my
expertise with the clickers across the
world tuberculosis is airborne disease
caused by Mycobacterium tuberculosis
Makka pakka chamber closest is their
intracellular pathogen it's many
infected macrophages in alarm and
survival and another case new
macrophages tuberculosis is currently
ranked as top of 10 causes of death in
the world above HIV at the malaria
according to a wh o deport one third of
a global population has been infected by
Mycobacterium tuberculosis
among those infected five to ten percent
of people with the web activity B
sometime during their lifetime learned
many ninety percent of infected people
we have latent TB infection in 2016
over 10 million people had additive with
T V because of TB infection leading to
1.7 million deaths including point four
million
co-infected by HIV tuberculosis is a
leading killer of HIV positive people in
2016 forty percent of HIV deaths were
caused by TB infection TB is their
poverty led to the disease a number of
factors Murphy mer facilitated TB spread
the first effector is a poorly
ventilated and overcrowded living and
working condition which may provide
ideal conditions for TB spread the
second factor is more nutrition and
other diseases particularly HIV which
may reduce body resistance to TB
infection the third factor is limited
access to health care it has been
estimated that one person with unshifted
TB may pass TB onto ten to fifteen
people annually based on a wh Oly pot
over 95% of TB deaths occur in
low-income and middle-income countries
this map shows you other global TB
epidemics
here we can see TB cases mainly happens
in the South and East Asia under stable
Sahara areas these two regions account
for over 85% of TB cases Uniworld seven
countries including India Pakistan
Indonesia Philippines China Nigeria and
the South Africa liya hai kabhi burden
countries late accounted for total sixty
five percent of global TB cases in 2016
in the most cases TB is a treatable
infection AIDS
however compared to legitimate the most
in fact States legitimate for TB may
take us six months up to two years
this table shows Euler recommended
combination treatment for TB sensitive
for the drug sensitivity B it includes
our eight weeks intensive treatment with
a for antibiotics as an added with
vamping pure dynamite and temperature
followed by 18 weeks continuing
treatment with isoniazid and rifampin
legitimately success rates for drug
sensitive TB is quite high is over 85
percent in the world in 2016 this table
shows you that four different new
competent combination treatment for
justice we TV here we can see the
advocacy km average settlement can
changed based on a different combination
in a contrasted to sensitivity be check
resistant TB especially moisture
resistant TB and extremely juggle eases
TB is becoming a public health crisis
and a health security threat
whe o estimated there were 600,000
new cases with resistant to Lulu
fainting the most effective anti TB
Chagas this first line and he be jealous
of which around half minion had much
Genesis that TB the treatment for
revamping resistant TB and the moisture
resistant TB is longer with more
expensive ender totosai jaga's there are
treatment regimens recommended by double
hl4 chuck resistant TB if we are last
for over 20 months or even longer time
the latest data reported through WH o
show a treatment success rate for much
Alice's TB is around 50% only 30% for
extremely juggled registered TV as I a
matching above tuberculosis is album
disease is clustered by am a competitor
and tuberculosis list slides sure your
pathogenic lifecycle of Mycobacterium
tuberculosis ela host a Russell
particles containing Makka pakka carrier
cells is called a baile patient with
activity and uptake by linear host the
bacteria is deposits in a lower lung of
the new host and the recruit the
macrophages to the in finishing site
this macrophages may become infected by
mecha patient per closes and the English
Angela new runs of macrophage
recruitment in alarm from the granulomas
la pena llamas is a well organized
aggregates of sales lisa has include
depression 88
macrophages and the leaf sites in the
early stage of infection the granulomas
to me facilitates makka pakka to growth
and spend the infection by allowing the
packet error to infect new Orion
macrophages
as to the development of adaptive
immunity in a new host the granuloma may
jiggles mega bacterial growth a survival
illa host however under certain
conditions macrophages unicornio mom
ain't gonna cross phase to form necrotic
or unicornio loma let necrotic alcoa
may facilitate bacterial growth and the
transmission to the new host for a TB
diagnosis led to a traditional method
wise Makka pakka to our culture the
second ones as they fasting in for them
TB patient disputant let left a
fictitious euler morphology of the
bacterial colony on a agar plates this
is where the patient's sputum was played
over seven eight eleven agar plates the
right figure shows us the fastest inning
for our TB patient spittin here we can
see this pink not bacterial this is a
mega bachelor cells this slide shows you
another sample of their pathology
analysis for TB patient alum here we can
see the cavity in the lung of TB patient
this me from the granuloma we also
consider this case eighteen granuloma
lesion in a lot of q patient under
chester x-ray analysis we can see a
light region in the TB patient lung when
compared to the health in the video in a
TB diagnosis we also wanted to know what
is the histological outcome in a lot of
Chim patient this slide shows you other
histopathological analysis for a TB
patient the land samples in a TB patient
example we can see a typical granuloma
this granuloma contain a central core of
neck logically pathology materia
surrounded by forming macrophages
epithelial macrophages
leaf sides signatures on a first row
shows you three examples of Casa
eighteen granulomas funds in a TB
patient alam the fig a allah first arrow
choose or early has 18 granulomas in the
lam offer people with a meteoroid cuba
closest never figure be honor first
enroll choose you a class of caz 18 when
you Lumas here we can see our typical in
a critical core surrounded by
macrophages and the lymphocytes
let us say on the first row choose our
audition in a human lung here we can see
a fibrous capsule and the net clotting
center the fig a on a second arrow here
shows you another example we can fund in
a TB patient we can see the cavity
formation here we just imagine a
granuloma in the to be patient to land
and so we wanted to know how the edge of
the Quenya low-mass looks like a figure
be on a sex rose you'll see other phe
staining for our TB patient lamp
sections here we can see on edge of
granulomas layer a fibrosis we also can
see in the list allegiance field pilot
lymphocytes and macrophages a Weiler
typical research is so important today
so we need to look at the current issues
we have in a global TV control the first
issue is that she be vaccine
Makka pakka change always PCT is only
less than the TV magazine it has been
used for almost a 100 years old since
1921 the efficacy of impervious BCG Wims
over time after vaccination
it has been fund PCG has no or little
protection against the pulmonary TB in
adolescence and
additionally PCG is not recommended for
hiv-positive infants because of high
risk of blood test and determination
pshe infection the second issue is TB
treatment as a matter of bath more and
more drug-resistant TB is found in the
world Soler new jaga's all regimens are
urgently required to clear jug resistant
TB we also need new jaggus all regimens
to shorten a treatment duration as a
measure above even for a check a
sensitive TB don't take us six months
it's a long time it'll be increased
their the check sensitivity be a
chocolaty reason the TV percentage in
leti be patient Soler knew Cho comments
the new drug and treatment may be
engaged to shorten their treatment
duration for the post-chat a sensitivity
TV and a jug resistant TB we also need a
new jaga's with low toxicity and a half
advocacy the third issue is a TB
diagnosis follow current TB diagnosis
you see we use mega popular culture as
the fastest stinging as a mentioned path
we also have a PCR based and the illest
have faced a diagnosis we also have red
skin test for a TB however there's no
efficient TB tools we can use to
discriminate lately infection and
activity B infection so we needed to a
efficient per marker so we can use it to
efficiently discriminate based on TB and
activity B the inner human we also
needed a bar marker we can use to
determine treatment outcome as a
measuring for a TV to demand is a long
term duration so we needed to have a bar
marker we can determine the treatment
outcome but not using a bacterial
culture as a in this case we may
decrease their opportunity for
drug-resistant TB
occur
the typical OSI research we have asked
to understand the pathogenesis of Maca
patentable process we also we also help
us to understand their host defense
mechanisms in the content of makka
pakka's og-pog closest infection the
typical study we are also have asked to
develop new TB diagnosis tors new
magazine and the new NDTV checkers and
the regimens animal studies is necessary
you know TB research least rescues you
the current available animal models it
has been used in the TV research they
include dividend species for mice
rabbits guinea pig zebrafish
and monkey the monkey is a non human
provides animal model unit TV research
to mimic the progress of a TB infection
TB patient is necessary animal model to
develop human-like granulomas in alarm
for both rabbit and a quick creamy peak
a human-like granulomas can be found in
a lung after em TB infection here we
concealer network or in a canoe Lumas
from both rabbits and guinea pig alum we
also can say this necrotic core
surrounded by macrophages and
lymphocytes however in early study it
was fund Latonya Lomas formed in the MTB
in fact mice there's no necrotic core
additionally the package here is use
jiggetts in the macrophages is not
released to Loretta cellar environment
as we find in the TB patient granulomas
we also can see a typical necrotic or in
a granulomas here we consider natural
core surrounds the Beyler macrophages
and lymphocytes so this is a typical
structure of the granulomas we can see
in a TB patient we can see
listen figure a here I just mentioned is
a typical TV granulomas we can fund
inner monkey after HIV treatment a
hidden granuloma characterized by a
central area containing rescue
epithelial macrophages with permanent
features of evolving fibroid pressure
can be found in the lung of monkey it
provides a very good model for HIV study
to develop new NT TV judges and their
regimens other type of granulomas or
lesions also can be find in the lam of
monkey of the jagged settlement the
fricassee here can show you a pulley
circumscribed areas of interfere
fibrosis with and without prominent area
of cellularity
in lumps of monkeys of the geology
terment so this - also there kind of
revolution of the java children - more
similar to our healing granulomas the
figure D here shows your knowledge
example we can say in their monkey so
this is our fibroid healthy fig
granulomas with a central area of
mineralization surrounded by prominent
peripheral fibrosis so the monkey
provided very good animal models so we
can use it to develop anti TB Javas even
anti TB magazine in an animal study of
alt TV there's one questions how we
determine which animal models we need in
a study this table partially provide
provides a la carte line and to ask how
to select animal models you know to be
research here we can see you rabbits
guinea pig and a nonhuman primate we can
see the development or necrosis in open
your lomar also a castration and a
cavitation
in alarm
- m TB infection let us know cavitation
can be found in a mouse model also live
feel all very rare has 18 can be found
in a Atmos lamp after MTB invention and
a no necrosis
however because of small size
cost-effective and availability of
immunological agents most austere widely
used as mouse model energy research more
recently a new mouse model has attracted
the attention of sanchez dinner TV field
in this model in this mouse model we can
fund three different type of granulomas
after MTV infection and this mouse
models caught see 3 HD b FG and they
contain two different mouse backgrounds
one is the c3 h gb and then once f EG
background um this 3 different type of
granulomas i can show a show you here
therefore a type 1 when u granulomas we
also call the turbo varnishing here a
most similar to classic human TV
granulomas in which labor storage
encapsulated case is called necrotic
lesion these lesions become evident 35
to 45 days after low dose m TB infection
in a muslim this lesions is originated
as a focal accumulation of foamy
macrophages
interspersed with neutrophils often
proximal to bronchus the peripheral
markings containing abundant loosely
aggregated epithelia auditor macrophages
interspersed with a small number of
scattered lymphocytes
the type to lesions is similar to our
laboratory progressive pneumonia
composed almost entirely
nutrious overtime majority of blood type
solutions had substantial increase in
size and the continuous central region
of has 18 necrosis now the central
illusion has evidence of cellular
necrosis and cell death and over time it
will be a similar to their type one
lesion the type 3 lesion in a c3 h EP FJ
mice with cellular information additions
let's were indiscretion able from
pulmonary lesions typically funded
publishing in the Pegasus mice the
policy in the plexus mycelium what they
used as animal model in HIV research
list let's use euler correlation between
the bacteria numbers with their across
by the pathology of the granuloma inner
lamb here we can see the Hat number here
we can see the high number of lebesgue a
cheerier in the lung the cost of much
bigger granulomas in a muslim however in
the load a bacterial number the size of
granulomas is much smaller as I
mentioned bath TB is spread through the
air from person to person
Latanya water particles containing a
mega packet area may be expelled into
the air when are present with infested
TV of the lungs the coughs sneeze speaks
English Zener can spread the TV to a new
host
therefore specific a personal protective
equipment and the laboratory is needed
of all TV research
for the animal studies of tuberculosis
pss-pss 3 facility is necessary to mimic
the natural infection root of TB in
human animals are infected arrow Sri so
this is a recommended in fashion route
for TB research this slide shows you
their arrows or infection device it is
water flow popular device unit TB
research this is a grass call
encouraging special system it may
generate aerosolized bacteria and infect
mice their instrument consists offer
large circular tank this also called
aerosol chamber let contains ursu clay
basket with 5 pi compartments for
animals
so this is our fab height shipped
compartments basket arrow so tremor has
a heavy lead mr. Hamlet with for looking
handles
let's lock larly tightly against the
heavy-duty gasps gasps Kate the lid also
has two UV lamps and it's on the side
analyse Nemecek come home during tech
decontamination cycle of instrument
operation the front of her instrument
contains our control panel with four
thermos full of various cycles of
operation and two air flow meters and a
- air control nose and the three holes
with the clamps used to attach the
nebulizer when the instrument is in
operation compressed air is flow through
the nebulizer and the produce a very
fine mist of the package chiller
suspension which is read his land
carried by Allah
warning of air flow into the air result
rember here this five-mist is name be
taught by animals within the basket
after air flow pass through the chambers
the air flow Lin Xie later / through to
h-tpa filters and our superheated
exhausted stack this is a austere stack
there where the air is subsequently
incinerated before release so in this
case we came and remove all the bacteria
particles before we listen to the air up
to learnable ization process the machine
runs a clouds decay process in which the
arrows or embers is purged with a fresh
air this may also help enjoying any
bacteria attached to refer of animals a
service of basket and their chambers a
final step is a UV light treatment in
which the UV lamp under lower lid comes
on and decontaminate the top surface of
the basket except the techniques we used
it to infect mice instead of is example
one we mentioned on a previous slide the
layers also other technique we can use
including intravenous injection and
respiratory injection intravenous
injection can be finished through a tail
wing or Rachel orbital sinus further
respiratory roots infection we can
infect mice using integer K in
cherishing or Internet so in fashion
for injector congestion laboratories in
searching to the lung of mice derogatory
recently we developed a new technique
for injured jerky injection this slide
shows you the assembling of this gene
caching system they are three main
components in this system Weiser
installation and platform let's see the
second one is the illuminator Lisa
adjustable Luminator used it to localize
8 the tricky of mice the third is the
glass test cater we first used 3d
printer technique to generate the main
part of installation platform here the
3d printer technique is based on their
process called additive manufacturing
this technique a 3d printer technique
it's becoming one more important right
now to create custom designed or
sometimes difficult to manufacture
products the fire for this platform is
available online it's free for everyone
you can find a link for this fire in our
paper after we harvest this platform we
also change the two different metal bar
once a crossbar with mouse inside higher
the settings adjustment metal bar we
first insert crossbar into the main part
of the installation platform and an
inverter adjustment bar into low one of
the three horse inner platform so we can
adjust the height of the crossbar
according to the size of animals in a
study
after we have the assistant assembled
after we have list system assembled we
need to prepare mice so we can enjoy to
the mice we use inhalation as a flooring
to anesthetize mice in a heavy glass
desiccator as I assume heap as I assume
here a glass desk ater the mice were
then wanted to ensure sufficient depth
of anesthesia
Absalom Isis ready for injection each
Mouse was gently suspended by its
superior incisors on the mouse inside
the hanger and its body placed on tutor
slot on a bevel this is a slot on a
bevel of the platform let's got ugh
adjustable illuminator with a double
gooseneck was positioned near the fair
Engel epiglottal ijen of lamaze neck
platen of the mouse was gently pulled
out to the left side using small
scissors and elem pushed it down with a
micro spatula the check here was
visualized a by her perky 10 years chin
similar a chance illumination using the
light image the flan the end of a
gooseneck of fiber-optic end 30 to 50
percent of samples this is a bacterial
suspension were gently inject into the
lamp by integer care injection using a
band of research pipette and
juror loading tips after injection
llamas were wrapped with a clean paper
towel and return back to ler new cage
mice worm wanted until they were fully
recover follow and
seizure the figure here shows you the
yield of purgatory in lamb
one day after ingestion here we can say
90% of packaged food is injected into a
lot of mice efficiently to determine the
bacteria numbers of burdens in the
different organs and the organs can be
harmonized using hand operated tissue
grinder
GSU's Euler glass hand operated teacher
grinder we also can use electronic power
a grinder and we shall be careful we use
the this tool and tissue grinder and the
experiment should be done in the
passivity cabinet the urbanization
process meeting rates significant error
also hazard so their glass palace
connected to ler safety cabinet is
highly recommended especially for
especially for electronic power grinder
um next question is what's si we can do
or perform in an animal study for
tuberculosis we can look at the bacteria
input our burden given the organs by the
bacterial culture on the agar plates or
use as the fasting follow organ sections
we also can look at histopath illogical
change in their organs and samples using
AG staining or immunostaining um an
experiment we can do is we can perform
fro cytometry a lateral flow cytometry
algae PCR even Ani sequencing our Eliza
to look at the human immunological
change our response in the tissue after
Emma TB infection for all cytometry can
used to determine different populations
of immune cells after empty being
fashion and the sea which publishing of
immune cells is important to kill
bacteria our facility the bacterial
growth in Leticia rt-pcr can be used to
determine specific host or magnetic
material unless you know tissue unease
sequencing is more powerful technique it
can be used to determine or post or
Makka pakka Keira gene expression
profile in the certain tissue after em
TB infection Eliza is used to determine
a sub kin or content production and
Inlet issue we also can use the practice
samples from the MTB infected animals in
abusing this blood sample we can look at
the different hosters proteins such as
the substance of a common hands and we
also can look at the peripheral profile
of a blood cells in a whole blood of
animals to determine which a which cell
type is important to kill bacteria in a
TB biomarker study we can look at their
specific biomarkers we can use it to
diagnosis TV in the future in a anti TB
drug study in we can look at the choice
turbidity in the animal blood in this
case we may develop more effective or
stable ndtv jacks the tuberculosis
research is important today as a measure
but it will have asked you to understand
the bacterial pathogenesis
in a host and also understand the host
unit and adaptive immunity response to
HIV infection the study we have asked to
do develop new or more effective TB
magazine and engine TV dragons and
rudiments also have asked to find the
new TB diagnosis tours
and the final goal of relativity
research is to contribute to their
global TB control and a finally found a
solution to end the TV inner world and
finally I would thank you for your
attention I'll be very happy to take any
questions
Thank You dr. Chang for that informative
presentation we will now start the lab
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation when know type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is how to measure how do
you measure microbacterium numbers in a
stock use and infection
it's a good question we do need to know
the bagaturia number seeing us talk the
list will be useful for the infection
and to determine the constitution of a
bacterium stock the Makka pakka tier
suspension this which we get from a
stock is diluted in PBS in a temple to
Sirius and the name preached on stem H
town of 7-eleven a Capades the bacterial
colonies I counted three to four weeks
after incubated at 37 degree before we
start the experiment
the ola stock is learn stock is stored
at minus 80 thank you for the answer our
next question is how many mice may be
infected once using glass coal aerosol
device and is any anesthesia reagent
needed you one cycle up to 80 to 100
mice may be infected when we use the
baskets with the 5pi shipped compartment
as a shoe on a slide but sometimes we
also cast uses smaller baskets in this
case to be killing for the less mice in
a infection no anesthesia agents is
needed
thank you
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question last question is how does
glass cold inhalation system get
decontaminated post infection and
sterilize the air flow before release
during the experiment this is a
excellent cartoon and because of the
stivity is always the first concern
follow researches when we will corner a
tuberculosis so when we use the glass
core system so there are different steps
we can decontaminate the first is
donating the infection before release
into the air the air flow is passed
through to H EPA filters and then our
superheated exhaust astac net instant
incinerated any less T of particles as a
measure on a slide the second days after
infection there is the crowd in K step
in which the chamber is a purge with the
fresh air they can removed any
university adventure on offer of animals
English service or a basket and a tremor
after this step is laser treatments with
a UV light as I mentioned this UV light
is and Allah leaves the underside of the
lid and this UV length is comes on net
we contaminate the top service of the
basket
the third is after infection finished
learnable eyes and the plastic basket we
are be removed from the arrow so device
and out craved the service of the
chambers is decontaminate using beans
[ __ ] and thanks I would like to once
again thank dr. Jung Chang for his
presentation I would also like to thank
labret for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know the today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you will receive an
email from labyrinth letting me know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event but it's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon
goodbye